(upbeat music)
- Why would she let him die?
- Oh, honey, it's OK.
It's just a TV show.
- It's right there in your backpack,
how do you not see that?
Oh my god.
- It's just a TV show.
(kids yelling in the background)
- Hey babe, I'm just
gonna come brush my teeth.
- No, no, no.
I'm going number two.
Bye.
(sigh)
(jazz music)
- Oh my gosh, is this
your slow roasted pork?
- Yeah, I did it all day.
- Oh man, this looks amazing.
Here you go. (giggles)
- Oh.
- All right, you're gonna
play soccer with one cleat.
We warned you about getting
your shoes out ahead of time.
We gotta go.
- Wait, have you eaten yet?
- No, it's OK.
Thank you.
- Mm, mm, mm.
I thought this was your favorite movie.
- I've seen it a million times.
- Baby.
Come on, I thought this
was your favorite movie.
- I've seen it a million times.
- But it's so good.
So good.